if you want to change your life change
your outcomes it starts with you
changing your consistent morning routine
you have to figure out what the best
morning routine looks like for you and
that can come from trying on different
people's hats and their schedules but
you have to have something everybody has
something nobody just wakes up and then
hopes that amazing things happen not
people who are successful a lot of
people wake up like that most people
wake up and hope something happens to
them hopes that when the lottery hopes
to get the promotion hope some big
customer calls them right we're just
living in a land of i hope something big
happens to me but i don't believe it's
going to as opposed to demanding
excellence from yourself every day and
it begins with your morning routine so
how can you do it i'm going to give you
a three-step process that i think will
help step number one is figure out what
makes you sore so i said this is the
most important part of my morning
routine what makes you come alive and
soar what makes you feel like the work
that you do matters and you have to show
up today so for me i have to think of a
message every day i think about you guys
every day i wake up i'm here in my
toronto condo it's hard to imagine that
300 million people have seen my videos
that number doesn't make any sense and
so it's easy just to wake up and just
continue to live my life me my dogs my
wife and my condo and just another okay
day i have to remind myself that the
work that i do matters i think of a
message and then i share it and i take
up my phone and i post something to
instagram typically and that sets me up
that reminds me that what i do matters
is meaningful i need to demand
excellence for myself what is it for you
maybe it's creating a piece of content
maybe it's making a video maybe it's
watching the video maybe that maybe this
is part of your morning routine thank
you and it helps you soar right maybe
it's doing a good deed maybe it's
meditation or prayer or walking the dog
or playing in the in the sun like
whatever it is
what makes you come alive you have felt
it before you have felt it before you've
had moments in your life where you were
bold confident unstoppable powerful
where you felt like you could take on
the world right well you felt like your
crazy ideas were possible you felt that
before i know you have the problem is
the problem is it's not consistent
you're not consistently feeling that way
and so you need to reverse engineer
yourself before you worry about taking
on other people's routines and ideas
which are definitely helpful reverse
engineer yourself to figure out when in
your life did you feel the most bold
confident powerful alive and what led to
that happening what led to that
happening and then put that into your
morning routine demand it from yourself
every day
right so it could be reading it could be
watching video all the things i talked
about it doesn't matter you felt it
before
reverse engineer what that thing was and
then put it into your morning routine
because if you woke up and you did the
thing that made you sore then would you
feel bold unstoppable powerful confident
every single day holy cow get ready for
a massive change in what your life looks
like over the next year step number two
is ask the high performance coach
question so again i'm going through all
of this stuff with brendan
i'm going through all this and and my
favorite question
was the one i read
if i was a high performance coach is
what you should ask every day i like
this if i was a high performance coach
looking at my life from a high level i
would tell myself to remember that
because it's so easy why i love this is
it's so easy to look at other people's
lives and say what needs to be fixed
right
you can look at your spouse your friends
your team your parents your siblings you
know your high school mates whatever you
can look at other people and say
that needs to be fixed you got to go off
and do this right you you become the
high performance coach for other people
and what i love about this is that
you're looking at your own life
today as a high performance coach what
would you tell yourself
and then they have one at the end of the
day
uh if i was my own high performance
coach i would tell myself this statement
about today so of all the things on here
it's a great format i like that the best
since i would challenge you for the next
30 days to ask yourself that simple
question if you were
a high performance coach looking at your
life from a high level you would tell
yourself to remember that what
and then step number three would be
which three people can you model their
routine so brendan you know he's got his
and i'm i'm modeling this for at least
30 days i've added you know john assaraf
a friend of the channel been on a couple
times uh talks about writing down your
goals
every day and then and then touching
them right so i'll write down some goals
and then i and then i write them every
day now and i'm touching them right
that's what he does great again you got
to see what's going to work for you
maybe i do that for 30 days and stop
maybe maybe it's what i do for the rest
of my life i don't know you won't know
until you do it consistently enough so
pick three people who you like pick
three people who you respect who you
look up to say this is the kind of
person that i want to learn from and
then go investigate how they start their
day and then and then try on some of it
right you might love the rock and he
works out for four hours a day you may
not be able to do that but you can work
out for an hour a day right because
maybe you're doing nothing every day so
it's a good starting point like just get
to the gym and start working out every
day right so pick three people who you
love look up to respect admire and then
go research what are their morning
routines and how can you apply one thing
from each of them to see if it works for
you rule number two act on your ideas
chasing down your dream is scary chances
are nobody around you has done anything
close to what you want to do and they
don't understand you they think you're
crazy well you know what here's a news
flash you are crazy and you need to
embrace your crazy ideas right now or
you'll regret for the rest of your life
that you never took action so i'm a big
believer that you need to trust your
crazy ideas that when an idea comes to
you you have to go off and do it you
have to teach yourself that you are a
genius therefore you come up with genius
ideas and you need to birth them into
existence because it came to you
therefore it's good at least that's what
i tell myself
and here's a quick example
i started a new channel last week
featuring ig lives of different
entrepreneurs one of the things that
frustrated me was that people your
heroes people that i love that i look up
to that you look up to are going live on
instagram every day and the lives
disappear in 24 hours it's just a
function of instagram is after 24 hours
the lives go away nobody can see them
anymore and i was frustrated for myself
and for you and that all this great
wisdom was being lost but i was also
frustrated for them for the for the
thought leaders for the experts for your
heroes that they're creating this
amazing content to help people and then
it just goes away and so i wanted to
help protect their legacy preserve their
wisdom and also have something for you
guys to be able to go back to again and
again and again
access to thought leaders and experts
and heroes and so i thought what if i
just started a channel with their ig
lives and i came up with the idea on a
friday and then on friday we launched
on friday i started with my own live and
we we had a live of one other person
and i put them up and we launched a
channel set up the email address set up
the banners set up the channel art set
up the playlist set up the rules and
then started training my team on how to
do it and so now we've got i don't know
how many videos a bunch of videos that
have been put up since we've launched a
channel and and that needs to be the
speed at which you start to move that
you get ideas and you don't sit on them
how many ideas have you had that you've
been sitting on for weeks four months
for years
when i when i travel and i meet
different entrepreneurs it it saddens me
so much to see so many people
have had a dream
for a decade plus
and still haven't done anything with it
the biggest problem is you're just not
acting on it and so you have to protect
your dream you have to you have to find
a spot that makes you come alive makes
you believe that you can do it but
protecting your dream doesn't mean doing
nothing on your dream right you have to
act even when the people around you
don't understand you think you're crazy
because again you are nuts it's amazing
and you have to embrace your crazy ideas
rule number three have shorter goals as
time has gone on i've become less and
less a fan of goal setting
and i love the idea of quarterly goals
over annual goals over a decade long
goals
because the timeline is shorter
and why i'm less a fan of goal setting
is because
the more you're actually growing
the less likely you're actually able to
predict where you're gonna be
so
i really hate 10-year goals five-year
goals 10-year goals if you think about
where you were five years ago think
about who you were five years ago five
years ago look at the calendar five
years ago from today
in the past who are you
you think that person
could predict where you would be
ten years ago
10 years ago i just started my youtube
channel
i had a couple videos up 10 years ago i
said i'd never want to write a book 10
years ago i wouldn't imagine that i'd be
here every year
making videos for a youtube channel with
300 million views in puerto rico because
brendan burchard invited me to his
mastermind group
to speak on stage in front of all these
successful entrepreneurs
i wouldn't have predicted that like with
with zero accuracy
and same thing for you 10 years ago you
had no idea that you'd be here not if
you're growing and this is the big
caveat not if you're growing like if you
can predict with accuracy where you're
going to be in 10 years
you can hit it but it's just way small
compared to what you could have done and
it means that you haven't grown in the
past decade
and so that's my main beef against goals
and and
having shorter goals having new miracles
can be great can be great like i want to
get 10 million subscribers on my main
youtube channel that's a good goal
but if i set that as my 10-year goal and
that's the only thing i'm gonna do then
it's wrong because probably in three
years i should jump off and do something
else
right i've been fortunate that
i've been doing youtube for 10 years i i
still love it it's still amazing but
objectives are your 10-year plans you
should jump off in year two and go to
something else because that thing is
actually better for you because you've
grown as a person
so at least that's great the advice that
instead of annual goals set it down to
quarterly goals because goals are still
helpful
they're so good to kind of track your
progress to know that this video did
better than that video that this
customer brought in more money than this
customer that are you doing enough
action to go and get the business that
you want
those are great
but as a macro
thing that's leading your decisions
i think the longer you stretch it out
the worse it actually is rule number
four serve others so in terms of making
decisions you want to do things that
will serve other people serving others
is hardwired into us they did fmri scans
of the brain and when you help other
people it hits the same part of your
brain as food and sex more than
receiving more than getting gifts is
helping others serving others being of
use you want to wake up every day and
feel like
the work you do matters that you're
having an impact we all want to go off
and have an impact you are built to
serve and so already in your decision
making does it serve somebody else does
it help other people in some way if it's
yes you're making progress in the book i
go through a three-step process who i
how so who your one word most important
core value what do you stand for who are
you you have one word that is more
important than all the others so
belief is my most important core value
and so already the decisions that i make
are through the lens of belief this
video is about belief i hope it's it's
my intention i may not always execute on
it as best as i can but it's always my
intention and so if you understand what
your one word is then it allows you to
make your decision making process a lot
cleaner a lot simpler a lot easier next
is your why your purpose comes from your
pain your why comes from your pain the
thing that you want to help and serve
other people with the problem that you
want to solve is the same problem that
you went through the people who you will
love serving are the people who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled with
your purpose comes from your pain and so
whatever was the most painful moment in
your life the moment where you felt the
lowest the worst the most worthless as a
human being your purpose for the rest of
your life is to help other people who
currently feel that way so think about
who you used to be who you were five
years ago whenever you were struggling
the most there's lots of people who
currently are like you used to be you
want to go serve them and then the how
becomes
how did you get through it how did you
get out of that problem you may not even
be fully out of the problem whatever you
struggled and suffered with you're not
done you're still growing you're still
learning you're still improving you're
still climbing that staircase you know
of knowledge and growth but every time
you take a step
up on the staircase you can reach back
and pull somebody else up one more step
one more step the more you learn and
grow the more you can pull people up
with you and so however you got out of
the hole even though you're not done
you're better than you used to be
there's lots of people who currently are
who you used to be and so however you
got out becomes a recipe to teach other
people as well rule number five find
what makes you happy happiness comes
from knowing who you are and then having
the courage and confidence to step out
onto that ledge step out onto the ledge
the ledge
and go live it and go be you
because it's hard because it's tough
because you're gonna get judged because
we're constantly comparing our version
of happiness to somebody else i'm here
in puerto rico brendan brashard invited
me down to speak to his mastermind group
these people pay 30 to 50 000 a year to
be a part of it and i'm honored to be a
guest and
the thing that i see consistently from
all the people who are here right
imagine if you're dropping 30 to 50k to
be here how much are you making
so that you want to come down right
everybody's doing the thing that makes
them come alive and that's the secret of
entrepreneurship at least the ones who
are successful
that your version of happiness is going
to look different than somebody else's
you're a weird duck that's awesome go
live it
brendan came on stage and started
talking about his daily routine brendan
doesn't do anything
work related typically until about one
o'clock he wakes up he walks the beach
he meanders he plays with his cat he
does all of these things that get him in
the right mental framework and his first
call is one o'clock
so he said i want you guys to try
something
tomorrow go and walk the beach right
walk the beach
try that first thing in the morning you
moved the start time we're supposed to
start at nine the start time to 10
o'clock because they wanted us to walk
the beach just as an experiment to see
and i i did it i went out walked the
beach and it was good
but it's not the thing that brings me
happiness
right living in a
tropical paradise
it's not my thing
i like concrete
i like the concrete jungle
i like being
steps away to everything
i like insane high speed internet you
know
the things that make me happy are going
to be different than brendan burchard
will be different than you
it's just about figuring out what the
heck is the thing that makes you happy
and then spending as much time as
possible doing that thing rule number
six build momentum if you want to be
thinking two to three years ahead and
still have success today then you need
to make sure that you have existing
momentum right now entrepreneurs we're
dreamers we love thinking about what we
can make two to three years down the
line it's an easy place for us to live
the biggest problem isn't thinking two
to three years ahead it's right now it's
that you're lacking momentum right now
in your business you're a genius the
only thing you're missing is momentum so
me personally i've actually tried to go
and do the opposite of this advice most
of the time uh it's so easy to live two
to three years out that i wanna now
focus on mission what am i trying to
accomplish the big thing that's never
gonna happen right i wanna solve the
world's biggest problem i don't think
people believe in themselves enough and
that's why i wake up every day trying to
help solve but it will never happen
and then what am i doing right now as
opposed to getting lost in what i can do
in two to three years because again i
think it's so easy just to live there
and then not bring it back to what am i
doing today to build momentum so i've
really tried to teach myself that as
soon as i get an idea for something to
start building momentum around it not to
get stuck in planning mode right it's
easy to get stuck in planning mode
here's where i want the plan to be in
two to three years you have to do jeff
bezos can think about where he wants to
be in two to three years because he has
an army of people doing work right now
building momentum on what's currently
happening if you're a solo entrepreneur
and you're just living in the future and
nothing's happening right now you're
never going to build that future so as
soon as you get an idea at least for me
i've been trying to teach myself i take
immediate action towards it it could be
something really big it could be
something like when i wanted to build a
house
i just decided i'm going to build a
house and then a year later i had my
house built right from finding a dead
property that was empty to excavating to
building a 5 000 square foot modern home
within a year i had my home built from
just having the concept and the idea
right
teach yourself that as soon as you get
an idea you don't just sit you don't
just plan you don't just tinker you get
out into the world and start doing rule
number seven alter your environment i'm
a big believer in altering your
environment i don't think that it has to
be physical to start so let me break
down a couple ideas for you that i think
will help one
your physical surroundings of where you
are right now what's on your wall what
you watch the youtube videos that you
consume hopefully my channel the books
you read all of that starts the process
of changing what gets into your mindset
more important than the physical
environment is this
it's what you're putting in here and so
you can start that from your home you
can start that from wherever you are and
i gained massive new belief in myself
from the video so my own channel from
consuming the content from guys like dan
and brendon richard and tony robbins and
all these people every day in my head it
pulls me up it makes me think bigger
makes me feel like there's something
more and injects myself with the belief
and so you can do that right now
immediately look at your habits look at
your routine look at the people you talk
to look at the the podcast you're
listening to in the videos you're
watching and is it part of a daily
practice it needs to be a daily practice
that you're putting that into here to
help you start playing a bigger game
rule number eight find amazing people
like me a key reason why you are not in
an amazing place right now is because
you do not have amazing people around
you think about it how many of the
people that you hang out with
consistently
make you feel amazing force you to grow
and push you to be a better version of
yourself you can't do this alone the
people around you need to change so you
can change so i recently came back from
a mastermind group in puerto rico with
brendon burchard and a bunch of super
successful people and one of the things
that i loved the most was how
he works with his friends
and there's so many people who say don't
work with friends don't with family but
he's built this group
of people who love working together
some have joined his team some are
business partners in different ventures
where they're genuine friends and
they've been friends for in some cases
over a decade
i love that model i love working with
people that i that i know that i'm
connected to i love working with friends
i don't see it as business is one thing
in personal something else maybe that's
just me i would much rather work with
somebody who i get along with than just
have a you know business relationship
and
that in particular made me think of my
friend mark drager and mark's got a uh
marketing company called phantom media
we had a podcast together called the
subnet podcast you want to go check it
out and i've known mark for over a
decade
and
he sent me a message not too long ago
saying that
what i need in a marketing partner for
my business isn't what he can provide
yet that he's still a little bit away
whether it's a year or two years or
whatever it is away from being able to
help me with what i need both from a
experienced point of view a resource
point of view
you know teen point of view that he
wasn't ready to help me and that he felt
like he was holding me back that if i
had somebody else then i would grow
faster
and
it never sat
right with me
until i went to brendan's event and then
what came back was realizing
i want to grow with mark i want to grow
with my friends i don't want to just be
at the top and then have a bunch of
business associates around me and then
my friends are like way down here right
i want to i want to build it together
there's value for me in building it
together beyond just a business roi and
i think ultimately long term it actually
leads to a better business roi
and i love that i love that brendan does
it and it provided a model for what is
possible for me to be able to go off and
create and build and so whether it's
mark whether it's alex from toronto dan
salsa whether it's jeremy from the
youtube coaching business that
we started together
i like being able to work with people
who
i can call friends
and i want to be able to do that more
and so whether you come on board and you
you you bring on your friends or family
uh definitely being around people who
push you who make you feel energized who
build you up who you could see for the
next 20 years being people that you want
to hang with i think is really really
really really really really really
really really really really important
rule number nine train the right skills
you are spending way too much time on
things that you hate doing that you
never want to be great at and it's
hurting your business
i'm here in puerto rico i'm speaking at
an event with brendon burchard his
mastermind group and one of the things
i've learned from people who've
accomplished a lot i've had big success
is that you are great at something right
you're you're the michael jordan of
something you have genius level talent
at something
but you're not spending enough time
doing it
you're spending too much time on the
things that you hate
that you don't ever want to be great at
that you can respect and say hey this is
important for my business but it doesn't
mean that you should be the one doing it
so i spoke at this event and i'm talking
entrepreneurs and they're thought
leaders and they want to have their
youtube channel they want to build up
their presence and brand name and
recognition and there's so many people
who when they get started they spend 20
minutes
recording a video
and then four hours editing it
to put the right graphics on to put the
right intro and extra music
now
if you are in the graphics business if
you are an editor then your stuff has to
look amazing
but if you're not
then you're training the wrong skill
this is the thing you're training
the wrong skill there's things in your
business that you're spending so much
time on that you never want to get great
at you're training the wrong skill you
should not be doing it
discount it
it doesn't mean you
get rid of it completely it doesn't mean
that you disrespect it completely but if
you're spending 20 minutes recording a
video and four hours editing it you're
training the wrong skill you need to
switch it you need to spend four hours
recording it
four hours recording it and 20 minutes
editing it
or zero minutes editing it i don't care
because people who are watching your
videos if you're a thought leader
they're coming for this
they're coming for what's in your head
they're not coming for how great your
editing skills are
now that doesn't mean you disrespect the
editing doesn't mean you never hire an
editor doesn't mean you learn xero
but the thing that will get you to be
able to afford to hire an editor is
making awesome content that comes from
here because no amount of editing is
going to save it if your ideas suck
it's the thing that holds so many
entrepreneurs back from making videos
if you don't want to make videos if you
don't want to be on youtube awesome but
there's something in your own business
that you're taking that same equivalent
to so look at your calendar look at
where you're spending your time look at
how much time is actually being spent on
things that are moving the business
forward that you love that you could be
the greatest in the world potentially at
chances are that number is like five
percent
and you need to move it that needs to be
85
that's when you start creating magic
and it's not going to be perfect
releasing that video won't be perfect
you're going to look at it and say man
that really sucks i would love to have
better lighting i would love that better
sound i would love that better editing i
love that better gear great
work towards it but that can't be the
reason why you don't post and it can't
be the reason why you're spending all
this time doing work that you hate
you can only do so much by yourself
i love being an army of one right when
you get an idea you have to do something
about it you wheel it into existence and
if people don't want to help you then
you will it into existence being an army
of one
but there's a lot of different ways to
win
you're going to win the hardest on the
thing that you're the best at
and so you start
and so you start and so you start
but you can't do everything
not very well
so you pick the thing this is the this
is the most important thing that will
help
give you leveraging your business to
help you turn from just kind of making a
little bit of money kind of making a
little bit of momentum to have a massive
momentum to making way more
leverage
figure out the thing
that when you do is fantastic
and everything else almost doesn't
matter and rule number 10 the last one
before our very special bonus clip be
proud of your effort the greatest thing
that you can do for yourself is be proud
of your daily effort it's not about how
many likes or views or praise you get
that stuff doesn't actually matter it'll
hit you and make you feel great for a
second and then it fades the only thing
that matters is when you're all alone
looking at yourself back in the mirror
are you proud of the person that you are
looking at and for too many people
it's no
and i want to change that in this video
so i recently came back from brendan
burchard's mastermind in puerto rico
with some super high level people
about 25 of us sat around the table
masterminded for three days and a lot of
people i've profiled here on this
channel
and i normally
hate
these kinds of events that are
open that are loose that require just
networking and talking to people write
it as a structure or if you need help i
love it if it's and just spend the next
hour and a half
mingling and talking to people i hate it
even the thought of it right now is
making me cringe i hate it so much
but when i got there brendan challenged
me to say
make sure you ask for help make sure you
don't just give give give give but that
you you leave here asking for help and
so
that's always been a challenge for me
networking events plus asking for help
we're hitting like both things that i'm
historically have sucked at and they
struggle with and so i decided i'm going
to be proud of my effort today i'm going
to go off and do it i'm i'm not going to
go home i'm not going to go back to my
hotel room right the hotel room was
super close
on that two hour break 90 minute break
three hour break i could have gone
back to my hotel room and done some work
i had lots of logical reasons why i
should go back and do work everything is
behind because i'm not working
but really it'd be an excuse because i'm
afraid because i'm afraid of staying
there because i'm afraid of not being an
instruction environment because i'm
afraid of just talking to people because
i'm afraid to ask for help
and so i decided i'm going to play
fallout i'm going to play for love i'm
going to maximize this time i've got
here
i'm i'm taking this time off for work
because i need to develop the
relationships i need to get the help
that i need to get and i'm going to i'm
going to ask for it i'm going to i'm
going to be proud of my effort even if i
fail even if i suck even if it doesn't
work out i'm gonna be proud of my effort
and it wasn't the most uh amazing
result right it was awkward i was
standing around and trying to join
people's conversations it was super
awkward and cringe-worthy but i was
proud that i did it i was proud that i
tried i can look at myself in the mirror
and said i did that i tried my best pat
on the back i'm amazing
for other people who are there too
they're naturally extrovert they don't
understand what it is to be introvert to
be shy to join in on conversations to
not ask for help and how hard that can
be
uh so for them it was easy
to just start conversations and
introduce themselves to me it was really
difficult but self-worth self-love
self-pride comes from doing difficult
things that you don't think you're
capable of and so i was really proud of
my effort for doing it and if you did
the same thing it's something i still
try to do every day
to be proud of my effort in making this
video i want to be proud of my effort
that i tried my best to make the best
possible video yet
you may not achieve it it may not happen
but if every day you woke up and you try
to do the thing to make yourself proud
right the effort you're going to create
amazing amazing amazing amazing things
where if you stay constrained by just
what you know and what you're capable of
and what you're good at you never grow
you just stay inside your comfort zone
forever and ultimately end up hating
your life now i have a very special
bonus clip that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and what are you gonna do this
week to take action on it so let me know
in the comment below so we're gonna
celebrate with you
working on your weaknesses is great
advice in basketball but sucks for
entrepreneurship because there's no such
thing
as a complete player in entrepreneurship
there's too many things to learn this is
the difference between the finite game
and the infinite game if you're familiar
with simon sonic's work the finite game
is when you're playing a game where
there are certain rules basketball has
certain rules right basketball kobe's on
the floor for a certain amount of time
in every game
can't just have somebody come in and
come out if you bring somebody in kobe's
got to come out you only have five
players on your team at a time there's
certain number of minutes in a quarter
right
there's rules
for entrepreneurship for life
there aren't as many rules
you get to play forever
in entrepreneurship
if you are the world's greatest jump
shot shooter
right take that equivalent
you're you're a billionaire
you don't have to go learn the other
things and it's in your best interest
not to
for you
to be great at one thing but then also
go learn
websites and also go learn coding and
also go learn copywriting and also go
learn speaking and also go learn video
editing and also go
there's too many things
and you'll at best become average at all
those things
so you're a complete average person
entrepreneurship is the opposite
what you want to do is find a thing that
you could be the kobe bryant of you are
the best in the world at something
you're the best in the world at
something
something in demand something in need
something where you can help people
and then go all in on that
so it's got to be that combination of
what you love doing with what there is
demand for
if you want to watch another top 10
rules of evan carmichael check out the
video next to me i think you can enjoy i
will see you there guys continue to
believe bye